do you seriously think i'd explain my
master stroke if they remain the
slightest chance of you affecting its
[Music]
outcome
uh so i'm recording this on
thursday uh this is a couple days ahead
of the
beginning of dc fan dome and that
is going on saturday and sunday
hopefully i have this video out on
friday and obviously
there's a lot of anticipation about
fandom there's already been some leaks
about
stuff that's going to be there we've had
teases for some sort of trailer
for um snyder's version of justice
league
there has been teases and hints and
leaks about
um ben affleck taking on the cal again
for the flash movie
and possibly something about the batman
stuff on suicide squad and all that and
it has
and i'm pretty sure my intention
completely drowned out the fact that
um warner media gutted dc
comics like badly
and i debated whether to put this here
or to put this over in the break room of
geeks
do subscribe there if you haven't
already because
this isn't the sort of thing i'd
normally eat up a video here on but
because i feel like this is getting
drowned out i want to bring attention to
it on the largest platform i've got
which is here so warner media
did almost a clean sweep of
the executive and creative heads
of dc comics almost everybody
is now gone now they'd already started
this process by booting dan
dadio earlier in the year and now at
this point basically the only one left
is jim lee and he's not in the position
he was in before he's not the publisher
anymore so he's been effectively demoted
and everybody else at the top
who is in the creative end of things is
gone
and this should be a bigger deal than it
is
again i i do strongly suspect
that the announcements of this
gutting i've got no other word of dc
is timed with fandom
so that the conversation around dc and
any google searches you do for news
about dc
shifts over to this like seriously i was
double checking my
sources on this and i a straight google
search
for news on dc none of it's about this
anymore it's all been flushed out
because of fandom leaks
the heads at warner media basically
looked at dc now this isn't dc
entertainment
this isn't the the film cinematic
division we're tired we're talking just
the comics
the prince the origins of all these
things
and like i said they cleaned house
and it's very telling that this wasn't a
reshuffling
this wasn't a taking out some of the top
people moving others
up from with it this is just this was
just clean sweep
bunch of people just gone and no
real immediate announcements about
seeing about any significant people
replacing them
or at the very least significant people
who already exist within the industry
this should be troubling for a number of
reasons there's the broad general reason
that
this is a corporate entity
basically kneecapping its own
subdivision because somebody in the
accounting department said
you know it's actually more profitable
if we fire a bunch of people
and cancel a bunch of what they do now
i've done a core on
a rant on corporate structure and some
of my
issues with it haven't worked in that
environment for a long time
over on the break room of geeks so you
can see my thoughts there
for that but this is not altogether
unexpected because
ever since a t bought
time warner this sort of thing was going
to happen
and that is what happens most of the
time when a larger entity buys a smaller
one particularly smaller one with a lot
of different divisions within it
because these things something like dc
comics has been
built up over decades by people who love
the work people who are attached to the
characters
the medium this means something to them
and now they are under the financial
control of people who as far as they are
concerned this is only numbers on a
spreadsheet
and if those numbers don't say what they
want they're going to start cutting
stuff
they have no emotional attachment to
this and i'm not trying to judge them
for
i'm not i'm not being like ooh the evil
corporate overlords but i am going to
say that um
you know you know who does have an
emotional attachment to this are the
fans who have been buying this stuff and
made the ip worth a darn anyways but no
that
they don't care and it's also worth
pointing out with fans that fans
are what make up the bulk of the
comic book creating industry because the
thing is
comic books getting into that is like
well it's like getting into youtube
or burlesque to make the comparison to
things that i myself do
there are some people who can make a
decent living doing it but if you go in
trying to do that you're going to be
very disappointed very quickly you get
into it because you
love it you love the medium you love
what can be done with it you love
the work and if you're very fortunate
you'll be able to pay your bills with
what you do there
nobody makes the aim to get into comics
for the money
and so when people take over who do have
an eye
on money even above you know what your
normal executive of a company like that
would be
they're just going to start cutting
stuff now does this mean
the death of dc comics as we know it i
well
it's hard to say there were obviously
plans in place there were things they
were working on doing
that are at best up in the air
there's gonna be and has been recently a
ton of book cancellations
if i were to make a guess basically
they're going to start treating the
comics division
as something that is home to
the things they want to make movies out
of specifically and that's it
and that's not an altogether new
mentality i mean it's the reason that
batman gets four books while things like
hellblazer and young justice
and teen titans all get cancelled
but i hate that i'm about to do this
like here's the thing i don't like
when events like this force me to praise
disney because i have a lot of pr well i
have a lot of problems with any company
the size of disney nothing should be
as big as disney is and own as many
things as they do
but to make the comparison because
disney owns marvel
disney specifically set out to a
to acquire marvel and has
let them do what they do and be what
they are
and disney seems content to let it be a
test kitchen for things that they can
then market in other media
but they didn't they didn't step in they
didn't take over
now maybe part of the problem is that at
d strictly speaking
didn't buy dc comics they didn't set out
to acquire dc comics they said they set
out to acquire and did acquire time
warner media
which happened to include dc comics
it basically makes dc comics the
unwanted stepchild
att married time warner and with it came
this kid that
they don't really care for whereas
disney actually
wanted marvel specifically and sought
out so maybe that's at the heart of what
the difference in approach is but it's
very telling that
marvel has been allowed to experiment
and do some things that maybe
they work and maybe they don't but even
if some
initiatives or whatever fail it doesn't
result in the company getting
gutted because then what good is it
the only time it makes sense to do that
is if you're looking at only through the
lens of
what is the what does the spreadsheet
say what are the numbers
say and the considerations of are we
engendering ourselves in a positive way
to
the audience are we going to upset the
people who made this ip valuable in the
first place those sorts of things are
secondary at best if they are even
considered
and in addition to this you've also got
the dc universe app and streaming
service that's
clearly on its way out pretty much
everything has already been shifted or
is being shared
with either hbo max or the cw
and there's a pretty good chance that
that thing's just going to go away which
is also going to be a mistake not
necessarily for the streaming aspect of
it i think streaming shows specifically
on that was always a mistake
but dc does like they can
benefit from an easy way to access
their comics digitally again marvel has
marvel unlimited
and whether or not you like marvel
unlimited as an app it's very
good to have a way for your fans to come
in and start going through your back
catalog
in a you know a nice little one-stop
shop kind of way
and i strong well it's pretty much a
guarantee that all the streaming
stuff is going to go off of dc universe
i would be shocked if dc universe
doesn't just get
shut down maybe not immediately but i
would be shocked if it still exists
within a year and
if that happens which i expect it will
that
is also going to be a mistake they're
making it
harder for people to get into these
characters
now granted dc as
actually dc comics has done plenty of
its own damage
when it comes to that dc comics
as much as i am frustrated by this move
i
i'm not about to defend the creative
choices of dc comics over basically the
last 20 years
i will admit to being more of a marvel
person than a dc but i have a lot of
friends who are dc readers
and i watch the pain that they go
through every few years
as they get their hearts ripped out and
gutted
by the moves that happen over there and
have been happening
so i wouldn't have objected to a shift
in creative
spirit you know bringing in different
people with a different mentality
as opposed to just and they're all gone
this has more the feel of like when ea
buys a smaller um
developer for video games and
and puts them on a project that is
outside that developer's wheelhouse
because it's what ea's marketing and
accounting department
says this is the genre that'll make more
money but that's not what we make we
make this sort of stuff that's why you
bought us because we make this
no we bought you because you added value
now make what we tell you
and then they do that and their fans
don't like it because it's not what they
wanted and they get shut down does that
mean that dc is going to completely die
well no
no dc will always be kept alive if only
for batman there will
always be batman comics probably more
than there should be
but i think any sense of
expanding out from that anything that
extends farther than the core justice
league members
batman superman wonder woman
the league itself anything that is
ancillary to that
it's not going to get its own book
anymore i think we're going to see a lot
more cancellations
of niche and sleeper hits which were not
necessarily unprofitable but
but just weren't as profitable as batman
is
therefore they can go away
this bums me out and it infuriates me
that it's kind of a lapsed news item
already
because here comes dc fandom
where they should be made to answer for
what's going to happen to the comics but
they won't be made to answer to that
because they'll go look snyder cut
bat flakkin flash which look
as far as that news item goes let us not
forget that the flash movie has
been completely retooled from the ground
up like
six times they've had a half dozen
different writers at least as many
different directors
it has been and the writers haven't just
been rewrites it's been like page one
start over
massive rewrites from the ground up
i believe them when they when we hear
they want ben affleck to come back and
be batman and this i don't believe it'll
happen
until it actually starts filming and we
get on set photos
until then until i see onset photos and
i know it's actually filming i don't
believe
literally anything that anyone says
about a flash movie
i just don't i'm not saying that this
can't happen but like i'm not taking it
seriously
until it's actually filming
and i'll try it i will
probably do some kind of a wrap up and
overview
of fandom after it happens but
ah man there's just a cloud over the
whole thing and i'll try and be more
positive
uh about it when i do that i say try i
make no promises at succeeding
i am a cynical bugger
but yeah
ahead of all that i needed to remind
people
that even as they are celebrating
the multimedia and the ip
value of dc comics
they are tearing the heart out of it
this is a live autopsy folks
the corpse will keep squirming and
emitting little gurgles in the form of
basically batman comics and
milking watchmen some more but
i can't imagine that dc is going to
ever be again what it was which is
a comic book publisher run by people who
are passionate about it
people who are making decisions that i
did not agree with whatsoever but
who were passionate about what they did
that's done and unless
someone else swoops in to buy
specifically dc comics
out from under um a t
because i mean 18 t obviously they're
going to keep warner media they bought
it for a reason but if
unless someone comes in to buy that set
of stuff specifically
somebody who cares about it ideally not
disney
they should not own both of the big two
oh god
but unless that happens
i don't see
a lot of stuff to look forward to at
least on the comics front specifically
maybe movies will still be good maybe
we'll still get decent anime stuff like
the harley quinn animated series but
the thing that started it all the comics
this is not good hate to be a downer
folks but
that's just where things are at right
now dc
comics having the axe brought down not
on its head but on
a number of appendages what do you think
about it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it usual
stuff to do you know what it is like
share subscribe
i have a patreon that is a huge help it
keeps the lights on
and ensures that i can eat but um
you also don't have to simpler things
um like links down the description to
other social media
and and the other stuff that i mentioned
before the likes to share subscribers
they also help but
you don't have to do any of it if you
don't want to because end of the day
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you um
[Music]